I'm 27 and I'm trying to keep myself
going every day and I kind of struggle
sometimes so what is your take on that
what do you struggle with brother I
think just being motivated to get to my
angle what's your angle honestly six
figures have a big house I'm being a
little materialistic but well that's
what that's why you're struggling
you're literally the hypothesis I have
of why people are unhappy you just meet
up an arbitrary goal for yourself based
on material things without realizing the
second you walk into that home and you
make six figures nothing's changed damn
that was
I would rather be you know have someone
be honest with me you know so even
better brother I'm telling you from the
deepest levels of love that you can even
imagine I know you I've met a thousand
of you all of them have lost the second
they got there you've been able to turn
your perspective to something that's
very easy to turn your perspective to
the world is very good at selling this
it's just super not true bro